oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you see [ __ ] dingo ate one thing from
the deli in New York last week Ric
Ocasek
70 looking like casing and took a
picture of Ric Ocasek with bang in the
model oh [ __ ]
it's time to [ __ ] is set the air of bad
free [ __ ] Wednesday 2:00 o'clock
coming at you direct from the Voodoo
Lounge I got three different types of
weed maybe four who gives a [ __ ]
I got Matt Lauer gee I got you killer oh
gee I got oh jeez for everybody for that
young saying I got the we brew more
smoke coming out tomorrow I got
everything
he got throw it out a little more that's
when you know you're a dead [ __ ]
freak well it's a beautiful day to be
alive you know I'm saying rest in peace
you dead [ __ ] anyway we're here
with Queen we're gonna have a little
special Church today and talk about a
few hot topics but as usual we gotta set
the earth man free cuz you gotta let the
good times roll I'm saying are you gonna
[ __ ] set the earth man free if you
don't let the good times roll
what a [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with look at Uncle Joe with his little
leprechaun shirt Galia man your little
[ __ ] Irish [ __ ] coming at you
from the Voodoo Lounge we're gonna talk
about sexual harassment and the [ __ ]
parameters now no more headshots with
women no more signing your titties
number one none that [ __ ] no more
that's it it's over it's over you know
I'm saying when a long time high and I
can't lose my [ __ ] job once a time
women always ask you to sign that
[ __ ] tits
I don't mind signing your tits I'd
rather smell your tits but anyway that's
a complete different therapy group and
I'm saying we're here we'll quit that's
all that matters the church coming at
you direct the cars first album let the
good times roll like I said we got
you'll kill og and [ __ ] Matt Lauer oh
gee I'm saying I haven't smoked the Matt
Lauer yet I gotta watch the news first
and get all the facts you bad
[ __ ] look at [ __ ] in the
afternoon banging a lot like soldiers
it's a no edible [ __ ] Wednesday
fillet I got it you know what I did this
morning
I got up and went to the 8:15 strength
and conditioning class at the YMCA ADA
who's better than me I was [ __ ]
petrified but I made that made the whole
[ __ ] class oh [ __ ]
Lee you ready for juquila oh gee [ __ ]
we're gonna write for the [ __ ]
oh gee wife talk around
hanukkah's around the corner everybody
wants to celebrate everybody wants to be
part of the party but nobody wants to
send out invites you know nobody wants
to send out [ __ ] and bites there you
go there's my dog right there ready to
go you're already starting to get spots
they don't let go so make sure your
bellybutton it's your spine
you're taking this bargain class hey
Anthony Robins got a class uncle Joey
got a class watch this let's do this
here you go
set that there you go that's the one
that's the one that's the one that's the
one
oh [ __ ] shuffling debt anyway is that
the to kill oh gee that's the one you
start the scratch you're getting
flashbacks and [ __ ] in a collapse
you just collapse you know we do any
other church nobody gets their turn
relax
you want one mama not really your hair
looks beautiful today by the way I'm not
that sexual harassment but [ __ ] can
you imagine getting pinched they're
telling a woman the hair looks good like
getting arrested like people getting
handcuffed this [ __ ] coming to your
office you told Felicia on October 13th
that a hair looks fantastic I'm in court
TMZ's there I got a picture we naked
just because that's that's the state's
evidence right there it's a beautiful
day to be alive [ __ ] you you're 6
feet above your breathing and that's it
that's the most that can happen there's
no debtors prison you understand me
there's no debtors prison smile [ __ ]
if she comes again here she comes again
[Music]
you know did sexual harassment the guy
in Greece not Danny Zuko but the other
guy Kenickie well he [ __ ] told the
girl to blow him at the movie Kingdom
I'm gonna press charges
it's all over gettin Olivia newton-john
of the pharmacy it's over you know I'm
saying we're pressing charges forty
years later I don't give a [ __ ]
understand me that's a great [ __ ]
movie I just played that video the other
like one morning I got up and I said it
was Greece the one jambs he sings
hopelessly devoted to you
tremendous tremendous I got chills
they're multiplyin but I was the eighth
grade I used to be in love with this
chick named Valerie and I used to hang
out with a guy and his girlfriend and
they was best friends so me and one by
Driggers used to walk the Harmon clothes
every day to watch it and I'd fantasize
I was Danny Zuko and Valerie was Olivia
newton-john like an [ __ ] who told you
that type of [ __ ] uncle Joey [ __ ]
who's doing a bong hit with uncle Joey
all right I see you I say a big dog I'm
just finishing this one off I'm saying
for good measure
I don't weigh the other side of the
ain't going Joey's blowing fake [ __ ]
bombs I'm gonna talk about some good
[ __ ] today
cuz I have questions I don't [ __ ]
know I don't even know what the [ __ ] I
don't know I mind my business I didn't
see nothing
you didn't see nothing what you were
standing right there tongue as it was
going down a meteor flew and you know me
I'm into [ __ ] meteors so I watched
the [ __ ] meteor one more bomb yet we
have to show started youtube.com slash c
/ Joey did you follow me you know I love
you [ __ ] yo Thursday night in
Sacramento that's all that's left your
miserable bastards no Friday no Saturday
you're left on Thursday but it's a good
night it's red star one night I'm gonna
eat like ten stars and go on stage and
just go [ __ ] bananas and don't forget
Sunday sandy no Hollywood Sunday night
no la Sunday night the no vote either
with my main man we will walk a San
Diego the fort the observatory and the v
Santa Santa Anna Observatory with my man
we love Walker go to wheedle Walker
comma something like that I don't
[ __ ] know you got questions go to
[ __ ] Google [ __ ] everybody
wants to ask me what time what do I got
to do joy which with the chitty-chat
either you're gonna burn that barn or
what let's do it
[Music]
are you kidding me or what youtube.com
slash c / Joey Diaz that's the place to
be [ __ ] and if you smoke pot and you
can't [ __ ] Drive call a lift I don't
know that's it and that's that mother
[ __ ] I know what you're waiting for
if you're sitting there see ass grows
roots get up do something with your
lives
uncle Joey youtube.com slash C / Joey
Diaz that's the place to be you dirty
[ __ ] I'll see you in 10 minutes